i use the board i'm going to do my best
not to say electrical flow except that
once
and
and i think i took the title of the
workshop too literally because what i'm
going to talk about has to do with
spectral and is fast because it's
inspired by spectral
but somehow the content itself seems to
be an outlier with respect to the rest
of the
workshops and
um so here's the outline slide
is a new model i think new
and then an algorithm
sort of a surprise
and an analysis outline
that's the
outline
um
this is oh what's the title right so
this is uh
sub sampled power iteration
that's actually just telling you the
entire algorithm
power iteration now you take a matrix
multiplied by a vector repeat this
it gives you some useful things like the
top eigenvector
or something in the top eigen subspace
sub-sample don't use the whole matrix
take a random sample and do it do with
an independent random sample at every
iteration
so that's the entire algorithm
what why are we doing this so this is
going to be a unified
algorithm
for
stochastic block models which i will
define in a second
and
planted
sat or constrained satisfaction problems
i should really say ksat kcsb
and i'll define both those problems in a
minute
okay
so
both problems have the following flavor
in common there are problems over random
instances so the instances are random
except that there's a solution planted
so they're biased towards a planted
solution somehow
and the planted the stochastic block
model also called planted partition is
the following problem with a
large literature
there's a graph
and
an unknown planted partition of the
vertices in the graph
edges within the parts are picked with
some probability p
edges across are picked with probability
q
and so these probabilities are different
and you'd like to
find the partition with high probability
using as few edges as possible
that's it
okay so recover
planted partition
um this this problem has a long
literature i should at least mention
uh so
1987 bopana gave an algorithm
for the bisection version this when this
planting was a bisection
then german sarkin used a metropolis
random walk-based algorithm
then there was a paper by diarrhoen
freeze blum and spencer
alone and kahale gave a spectral
algorithm
continent carp
gave another
iterative algorithm phigae and ophec
kohauglan
butcher
mcsherry
and wu most recently just just this past
year another algorithm based on svd so
it's a long literature
um
some of these works i should mention not
only for partition to two but you can
also talk about partition into k and
with different edge probabilities and so
on okay
we'll we'll talk about some of these
algorithms in a minute
i do want to mention a very nice
conjecture
that was made a very precise conjecture
that was made
three years ago by
the cell at all
and the cell
um and here's what they said if i think
of p as a over n
and q as b over n
where n is the total number of vertices
then
they said that recovery of this
partition
is not possibly conjectured
is not possible
if this is smaller than 2 times a plus b
and
is efficiently possible with the
polynomial time algorithm if it's bigger
than 2 so
impossible
and polynomial time
so
uh and this conjecture
was proven recently by
uh
masuli and also independently by
mosul neiman and sly
both parts lower born and upper bound
are non-trivial
you might wonder where this comes from
one high level explanation is that
if you try to run a process called
belief propagation on this graph
and ask when does it have a non-trivial
fixed point
you'll come up with a condition like
this
but beyond that i don't understand
exactly why this shows episodes it's an
exact threshold polynomial time
algorithm
okay um
now
what we're going to talk about now when
i get to the new model
so this new model should pick a
different color
is the
bipartite
planted partition
so there's something interesting happen
for equality
yeah what can you do at equality
i don't know
i would guess that it's not known
exactly what happens
so i can make this less than equal to
here impulse okay thank you
okay
this is
joint work with
vitaly feldman and will perkins
vitaly's here
okay so what is this model so now you
have a bipartite graph
um
v1 v2
and there's a partition of each side
a1 b1
a2 b2
the two sides don't have to be of equal
size
in fact i will
to emphasize that draw this
um
the edge probability
between
the b's
is p
and across his q
and the goal is again the goal let's say
is to recover a one b one
now you can solve this with this by just
identifying the two sides
so that's that's
those are equivalent
but the reason
okay so let me
let me state a result here
then i'll state the second problem or
we'll use the same
uh same model to reduce that problem
also and the second problem is very
different and then and then the
algorithm
okay
so uh
the the
statement here is going to be the
following
that uh
uh let me re-parameterize this as
follows
let's say that the
probability between of
on one side of the partition so the a is
one side the base one side
is uh delta p
and the probability
across
is two minus delta p
where p delta is not equal to one
so
this is to avoid confusion i'll make
this delta p here and two minus delta p
okay so then
theorem
uh and we want exact recovery the entire
a1 b1
uh
order
square root n1 n2
log n
over
delta minus 1 squared
edges suffice
okay n1 is the size of this one and n2
is the size of this
um when n one equals n2
um
you know that's that's
that's linear in the size of the graph
times log n and it's a lower bound that
matches that
uh
but when n1 is not equal to n2 let's
think of n1 is much smaller than n2 then
this is actually smaller than the number
of potentially smaller than the number
of edges in the bigger side
it's optimal up to a constant factor
and i would love to have a conjecture
like this for this version but i don't
know what it is
or if there is another one
which dangerous mean to exactly recover
a1 b1 okay whereas in the other case you
only got like some advantage
uh no no this is exact recovery as well
in the sparse case it's only oh right
right in this sparse case it's only
that's right that's right that's right
yeah yeah so here yeah yeah you pick up
these log n factors when you want to do
exact recovery versus
versus yes so that's right so to to the
the analog for the conjecture would be
you want to find something that's highly
correlated with the partition
um yeah
okay
so that's the
um that's the first problem and this uh
now here's problem two
which is uh
planted
ksat or kcsp
so
here let's
think of a
set of n uh variables so two n literals
ordered so
you know the literals are just index
them one two to n and one bar
to n bar
and uh a clause so it's going to be a
satisfiability problem you get a bunch
of clauses and you want to find a
satisfying assignment
um
clauses are just ordered
k tuples
of literals
and you can do it in many different ways
if it's just satisfiability you would
say
uh there's your clause so it's the or
the disjunction of these literals but in
a csv you might have a predicate for
each clause
somebody picks a predicate different
predicate potentially for each class
okay
now what makes it planted is that
there's a
we first fix an assignment sigma unknown
on all the
on the variables
and the distribution on clauses
so this is a clause
and the distribution of clauses is
affected by sigma in the following
precise way
so
the probability of a
clause
c
of this type catapult
is proportional to
let's say this function given by this
function q of c which depends only on
the
assignment values of the literals in c
so we picked a class x1 or x2 or x2 x1
x2 xk look at the assignment values on
those literals and q tells you uh uh
a number which you should which the
probability picking the class should be
proportional to so q is a function that
goes from
plus minus 1 to the k
to 0 1
not a negative function
okay so for example if you wanted to
pick a
satisfied uh
case k c and f set
you would make q
uh have probab q equal to one for all
clauses with at least one true literal
so as long as you picked one true
literal at least one that would be q
if you wanted uh uh xor sat you know as
long as the number of true literals is
even you make it one otherwise it's zero
and what's the problem recover sigma so
the problem is recover sigma
the question is
how many clauses to do this efficiently
to do this in polynomial time
now
like in this block model case
there's a huge gap here
and not a constant
between
what's needed information theoretically
and what we can do algorithmically
so if i'm going to draw a little picture
a little
plot
this is
the number of clauses
and this is a
let's say the number of
surviving assignments or satisfying
assignments
at any point
it starts out high all 2 to the n
potentially
and
there's a point here
which is just
proportional to n log n
where
only one
one assignment survives namely the
planted one
okay after you see analog and clauses
and this is i'm ignoring the dependence
on k here it's a function of k
uh the number of uh survival only the
planet assignment of course will always
survive let's say we're talking about
the case where
each clause can be satisfied then uh
then the planet assignment always
survives should we talk about cubing
like the ant function now
sat yes so cnn yeah exactly yes right
um we can uh i'll mention
the analogy for the general case in a
second but yeah let's just say sad case
then this drops off and then there's a
point here n log n that's the unique one
but at the moment the best algorithms
for finding it
need uh
n to the
k over 2 log n
there's a huge gap
for some queues
for for some distributions there exists
distribution here i'll mention one
specific one in a second
for which this is uh this is a
this line
now
it doesn't have to be the satisfiable
case let's say q just picks up a bias
towards the assignment
then uh
find the only
after unlocking clause is the only uh
assignment that will be correlated with
this distribution
threshold for the correlation will be
the planted assignment again that
threshold is still only in login
okay so
how do we explain this gap can we do
better so on
okay
um
now let me just mention we don't have to
go into this in detail but there is
another version of this problem
uh
which was
used by goldright to define a
pseudo-random generator
where what he does is he first fix a
picks a predicate and fixes it
and then
instead of just giving you clauses you
get these ordered tuples along with the
value of the predicate
so the clause the tuple value of the
predicate triple value of the predicate
in this form
okay
and the value of the predicate when
evaluated on the
on the on the head on the planted
assignment
so your goal is still to recover the
planted assignment so that problem has
very similar behavior although formally
you have to make the algorithms a little
different
i mean not the algorithms the analysis
um
okay so the i mean this this the
mystery here
now
the theorem let me state the theorem
here again and then
is the following so define to state the
theorem i need one definition
which is the distribution complexity of
of q so we'll call this the distribution
complexity
it's just a single integer
um
r of q
will be an integer between
1 and k
and it's the
size of the smallest non-zero discrete
fourier coefficient of q
so the
minimum
size of s
where
q hat s
is not equal to zero
this is the
discrete fourier coefficient
but
um
so it's some parameter distribution it's
between one and k it's k said it can't
be higher than k
and uh uh um
oh
sometimes it's easier to think of it as
the following it's the
smallest number r for which the
distribution q is r minus one y is
independent but not r y independent
okay so ro is independent but
not right independent but r minus one y
independent and so the theorem is
that order
n to the r over two times log n clauses
suffice
sorry a quick question right so the
login factors come because of some kind
of coupon collector
you have to
for the existence alone
greater than c and there will be no
satisfying assignment if you didn't
put one the only thing is that if you
only do cn random clauses you might not
see some of the literals at all yeah no
i so those can be assigned anything you
want right i agree so you could have two
assignments differing only in one
literal yeah and both would be satisfied
unless you go to n log n plus that's
right
now n to the three halves that log n
also comes together no that comes in our
upper bound that's why it only suffices
in terms of lower bound it's not at all
clear that you need a log in three house
lower bound we know for unsatisfiability
all of five or something right we don't
know any lower bond better than n we
don't plant one unsatisfiability i mean
i pick n to the three half's random
clauses yes then we have proofs proof
sponsors you can prove refutation yes
you can refute the formula but that's
still an upper bound if you have it's
only empty
it's like
uh maybe an algorithm by the way
but then you have an extra login
algorithm it's not only one point four
five year friend is that below one point
five now right okay so we'll use several
different ones right yeah
but it's still higher than what could
potentially the algorithm the the
formula becomes unsatisfiable at n
sure cn high
right that's with no planting
so this is it oh i should mention the
running times of both of these are
linear in the number of edges so that's
the fast part
so time time in both cases is
order of number of edges here
order of number of clauses
so this problem also has a
large literature so i won't try to
do all of that right now
so the next thing i want to do is look
this model the algorithm in fact is to
first reduce this problem to the
bipartite planted partition and apply
the run the algorithm to find the
partition
so next i'll describe the reduction
from
planted sat kcsb to a partition
this is in some sense this is folklore i
mean there's a special case for k equal
to three that's in a paper by bogdano
and ciao and then there's an extension
by apple bomb which is
maybe it doesn't appear anywhere but
it's attributed to him he he came up
with it so i'll describe
do it four-year degree and the gf-2
degrees
so can you get something
i mean so the minimum of the two yeah
right
now this is this
because the minimum can be high for the
parity functions
as big as k
right right so r can be k
r can be k yes
so in the parity case here you cannot
read the k as far as
you can use the if it's an exact
predicate then you can use algebraic
degree we're here
taking uh
that's right that we are talking about
general distributions where
you
they're rarely an exact predicate so
yeah so if it's like a if if the
distribution has to be happens to be an
exact uh predicate with a nice but low
algebraic degree then like at the parity
case or or in general more generally you
can do it yeah
so okay um
okay so the reduction from uh planted uh
let me do planted
clay sat
to uh
this bipartite
planted partition
has two steps the first step is to
reduce planted cases
to
to a particular distribution which is
noisy exhaust
rx or side where r will be the parameter
of whatever
distribution we have here so we have
some distribution q on the
in clauses to start with that has some r
and we'll reduce it to noisy r x or sat
so
that's one step and the second step is
just that noisy exhaust rx or sat you
can embed into
as a bipartite plant
now the first step just follows from the
definition of q
so what do we know about the difference
of r
what is r it's the smallest non-zero
fourier coefficient
so if i write down what that is
there is some subset s for which this is
not 0 let that be s
so this is the expectation overall so
it's 1 over 2 to the k the assignments
the sum
of the value of
so x is a plus minus 1 vector
times
you know the the
the
polynomial here which let me just write
explicitly i in s
of x i
right so this is the term corresponding
to s
and that's
right now
k is the
width of the clause the number of uh
literals so a clause is picking k
literals from that
okay so what is this
we know this is not zero let me just
separate it into the terms for the even
parity and the odd parity
right so this is exactly
times the sum of q of x
where the number of uh
so let's let's look at the absolute
value
the number of uh
x i's that are equal to 1 is even
minus
the number of x i's
equal to 1 is odd
because that's the only thing that
changes the sign
right now so excise in s in s
that's right the i is in s those are all
that matter for this
so you're looking at how many i's in s
are even how many i's in s are that
gives the function this is not equal to
zero so these two are different
so now here's our reduction what we're
going to do is take a clause
look at the literals that are in s
pick out those r literals that's your
clause that's your net clause for the
noisy rx or set
problem
take a clause from the original
distribution pick out the order literals
that are in the subset s that has a
nonzero coefficient that's your clause
in some cases pick you know you could
just try all possible s's if you wanted
because it's only
k k to the r of them
but
let's say the q depended only on the
number of true literals then you could
even just pick a random subset of r out
of the k
so
anyway this this this is it so
that's the reduction to noise er exhaust
that uh i don't know where zx are oh i'm
sorry
okay so
uh this is the problem where
um you're given clauses and i just have
to define the distribution if you look
at the xor of the literals
the probability that it's uh
so q of x
depends only on the number of
true literals in x
and
it's equal to
delta p
if the number of true literals is even
and two minus delta p
if the number of true literals is odd
and delta is not equal to one
so there is some difference between the
there's a bias towards one parity or the
other
and the predicate is just xor
if the delta was zero or one this would
be the
here's our problem you can solve by
gaussian elimination here it's the noise
each clause
this seems to be the root hard problem
in this whole business with the planted
satisfiability
okay but once you've stated this problem
it's starting to look like the
bipartite maybe at least i put in
parameters that look like it
okay so let me do the second step of
reduction
which is we have an instance of this
problem
you're given clauses
they're true
uh the probability you pick a clause
with an even number of fruit literals is
delta p the probability you pick a
clause with an odd number of true
literals
is two minus delta p and your goal is to
recover the the assignment under which
this this distribution goes
so
are you going to do this
um well we'll define a big graph right
so the graph
is going to have size n to the r over 2.
so somehow into the r over 2 has to be
square root n 1 n 2.
um
so the graph will be
the set v v1
is going to be
the set of all
r over two floor
ordered tuples
and v2 will be
ceiling r over two
are irritables
so
okay
so um
uh
if i
draw this matrix
which goes from v1 to v2
now what's the planted partition
i'll tell you what the planted partition
in this graph is a huge graph the graph
has size n1 equals
n choose r over 2 floor
and n2 equals
n choose r over two
ceiling
that's the size
now
um
the partition is just based on the
number of the true literals the parity
of true literals in this subset
so
here is a1 and b1 a2 and b2
so these are all the literals i mean the
the the r over two ordered triples
which have an even number of true
literals
and this is odd number of true
same here even
number of two soul
and odd number
now if you look at then this make this
here
a clause here if i just think of it as a
concatenation of this r over two floor
tuple in this ro2 ceiling table i get an
r clause
and that our clause if it's even an even
must be even
so the probability of a
picking something from here is delta p
again ord and r this is even so this is
delta p this is 2 minus delta p
and 2 minus
those are the probabilities in this
matrix
which is exactly the setting of the
bipartite planted partition drop
next so we took each clause and
um you know when you pick a clause you
get an entry here
so if you can now if i recover this
partition a1 b1 how does that give me
the assignment
well once i recover this partition a1 b1
i know these clauses and i know their
parities and i know them exactly so now
it's just gaussian elimination
i take n of these
write down
linear equation system mod 2 and solve
it
just singles n there's no this is much
smaller than
n to the other because each of these is
saying look for this clause let's say x
1 up to x r over 2 floor the number of
true littles is even so i know the
parity of that system is zero and then
so the last step is gaussian english
okay so that's the
all reduction
now
i'll uh
now in this talk
i'm just going to focus on the algorithm
the upper bounds for these
but
i do want to mention take a minute to
mention
that
we have
the following lower bound for this uh
for the for the planted satisfiability
problem or the planted kcsb problem
um
the lower bound is not for all
algorithms it's for a class of
algorithms that called statistical
algorithms
where you don't get to see the clauses
instead you get to evaluate functions on
the clauses
you can do this either by saying what's
the value of this function or random
clause from the distribution or give me
this function value within this accuracy
and in this restricted model where you
don't get to see the clauses but you can
only evaluate functions on them
it seems that we can run almost every
algorithm we know except gaussian
elimination
um
so
i won't
go into the
details of the model or even the lower
bounds
but in that setting
the algorithm we we're going to provide
here is optimal and you can't you can't
go lower than
um
then then into the r well n over log n
to the r over 2 clauses
so
if there is a better algorithm that uses
fewer clauses
it's going to be something that's not
statistical
if there's
questions or time at the end i can
discuss that more just to think about
the case of this that i usually think of
which is where we're doing actual sat
like q is and
okay then i guess this discrete fourier
coefficient even the first of them is
non-zero so what the heck happens
something
so so the point there is that you know
you get very uh
it becomes unsatisfiable very quickly
assuming there's no planting at all or
even if there is a planting though only
one survives yeah
okay we're just trying to figure out
does that mean anything in this
construction if i do majority let's say
yeah i can make the first coefficient
the zero order term zero but not the
next one right
but uh
somewhere this graph thing has to break
down right
or uh
which graph thing uh i mean if uh if i
is equal to one
what second oh if r equals one so so uh
yes so r equal to one case um
you can recover
uh most of the the partition
most of the assignment using only root n
log n clauses
but uh to recover it fully you need to
see an
end
then satisfiability isn't ours zero
um
you mean it's just uniform with no
planning at all
sorry i mean q is oh oh oh i see that's
what i see what's going on sorry i don't
mean
if if you just have a bias source like
having satisfied clauses most
unsatisfied
that could still have any r depending on
the distribution
depending on the distribution okay but
you're saying we can make distribution
but okay
yeah so
we can have distributions where r is
zero right and you can't get much out
like
log n plus right so this this this only
makes sense when r is at least one yeah
oh you did specified yeah yeah are
between one and k
okay
yeah if the function is constant then
yeah
um yeah so planted sat would be you're
picking this is say the true literals
these are the false neutrals your
clauses are hyper edges you're picking
at least one from the true side but you
could still have any distribution you
wanted on these and in fact you can come
up with distributions that are
completely satisfiable
but the r is
uh k minus one
so
yeah
not the uniform case if you just pick
uniform satisfied with at least one then
r is only one but but if you
if you did this then
sorry did you say that there's a is
there a regime where you can prove the
statistics
will not work and this
this will work no no so all algorithms
for which
all the upper bounds right now
uh are above the statistical lower
bounds the statistical lower bounds look
like n over log n to the r over two or n
over log n
log n inside the r over n over log n to
the r yeah
and the algorithm will describe now is
also statistical
can be made
this last step yeah but you see by that
time we're using gaussian elimination or
information that we completely have the
algorithm has recovered it's not
gaussian elimination on the clauses so
we can do whatever we want
it's just the interaction with the
with the distribution is through
functions yeah so the whole algorithm is
a statistical grade yes
okay um
well let me describe the algorithm now
which you've already seen but i'll just
make it
um the size
something like this
you are going to the bipartite yes the
the bipartite plant in particular
but actually before that i promised a
surprise and here is the surprise
um
so so we get an instance of this matrix
we can think of the input to the
bipartite planted problem as uh yeah
it's the same same
you know as a matrix where uh there is a
partition
and uh you have uh random edges from
from this distribution right these are
the expectations of each entry
so if you get the matrix m i can think
of it as the expectation of m
which is exactly this matrix
plus some random matrix right the
deviations
now the typical spectral approach which
is common to many of the previous papers
is the following
we say
let's look at the
norm of of these of these of this
decomposition
and as long as the norm of the
expectation is much higher than the raw
norm of the random part by finding the
top eigenvector of your instance
or the top singular vector you it will
be something that's biased towards the
expectation matrix and that's how you'll
recover
a lot of the partition
okay so this is how
along
or
baksheri's algorithm or wu's algorithm
work for example
so
in this case if i look at m minus
expectation of m
um
by the way just
to make this a little bit um
what i'll do is
let's call this matrix the actual
instance the adjacency matrix a
and then we define m it's just a slight
centering f a minus
we'll move it a little bit um
p times the all ones matrix
which is this
so if i do that then the expectation of
m
looks like
delta minus 1 p
1 minus delta p
so it's just rank 1. it's a rank 1
matrix now the expectation and this is
what you'd like to recover delta is not
1. what's the norm of this expectation
matrix
so it's rank 1. so it's the same as the
frobenious norm
so that's square root of
there's n1 times n2 entries
and then there's a
delta minus 1 squared p squared
okay so that's the norm of the
of the expectation
okay
now what about the random part what's
the two norm of the random
you see the random part
has norm
that depends on the bigger side of the
of the matrix it's n1 by n2 depends on
the bigger side of the matrix and it has
norm basically
square root p and 2.
you have to have mean zero also i guess
i already centered it right so m minus e
m is zero
this this is the expectation matrix
so r m minus e m
has mean 0.
but for computation you don't know e m
so
no not for computation this is just i'm
just saying arguing yeah so we'd like to
find uh something correlated with the
this vector
um it seems at the least the norm of
this vector should be higher than the
then the top eigen value of the of the
of the random matrix otherwise how could
you possibly find it the random the
noise is dominating
but if you look at that equation which
says square root n1 n2
delta let's ignore the delta minus 1
times p
is bigger than
square root p and 2.
this is requiring
p
to be
at least i square both n 2 goes away 1
over n1
okay
e remember is the probability of an edge
so the number of edges
is this times n 1 n 2 is about n 2 not
square root n 1 and 2 but n 2
so potentially much higher than uh the
the lower bound
but more importantly if if our p is only
about one over square root n one and two
then uh
the random part actually has more noise
more more a bigger norm than the
expectation
so finding the top eigenvector i'd give
you nothing
actually we don't know that just can't
so how could it how could you possibly
recover
this when you're damping with noise
that's much bigger it's a
order of n to the one fourth in norm
okay so here's the algorithm
um
just use a parameter
say l
equals 10 log n one
and we'll have matrices
m1
m2
all the way up to ml
these are independent
subgraphs
of the input
okay so basically take each edge and
assign it independently to one of these
copies now to make it perfectly
independent you have to do this little
trick where you might have to make
copies and do it but let's not worry
about that so what you can do is
you have the input which has
as many edges as we said we need
and take every edge assign it
independently to one of these copies
then uh remember that
mi they're a partition yes okay yes
they're a partition but a random
partition yes
um
now all i was saying is that when you
make a random partition they're not
quite independent
right even though they're almost that
you can force them to be independent by
playing a little trick and by
duplicating some edges and then
that's just for analysis
okay so mi is ai the adjacency matrix
minus
this uh
uh probability p over l times the all
ones matrix just as we centered here
let's just
moved everything all right now
we initialize we start with a random
vector which is just a random unit
vector 1 over square root 10 times a
random
plus minus 1 vector
that's the initial vector and then
here's the iteration
repeat
for i equals 1 to
l over 2
y i will be
m2i minus 1 transpose
x i minus 1 divided by its
noun to make it a unit vector
x i will be
and
then
zi
is the sine
of uh x i
so this is a vector every coordinate is
a plus minus one just the sign of this
vector
so it looks like just like the power
iteration right i'm doing x and y i do y
is mx x is my but each time we're using
a different independent matrix
um sub sample of the original and then
step four
is just take a majority vote of the z is
after the first login steps
so
for
i equals
l over 4 to
l over 2
um u
j say
is equal to the sine
of
the majority
of zj zi
so in other words i can sum up the zi's
and
sorry
sine of the sum of these
this step is just implementing a
majority
but not the first few iterations let's
say the second half of the iterations
um
and we output the partition given by
this uj
that's it output
partition
given by you
so that's the algorithm
you can tell us this does something that
just multiply by m m transpose
repeatedly yes we can't figure out
okay that counts
well i mean how we shouldn't be able to
do this right because
uh if this works you'd say why not just
fix the matrix to be the entire matrix
and do the power iteration
why bother to sub sample here that
should only create more error
and if you just fix the matrix and did
this
then
you should be getting something that's
got nothing to do with the
you you pick up the top eigenvector of
the random noise
um
if you stop after login iterations
and just take that vector the sine
vector
you'll have three-fourth of the
partition correct
the majority just make sure that you get
every coordinate right that's fine
yes
yeah okay so i'll just
sketch the outline of this
analysis
oh
in case you're wondering why is this
linear in the number of edges
x is short but y is long y has length n2
so we cannot afford to compute y
for the entire thing y is the long
vector
and the long dimension the number of
edges is only square root n1 n2
the long side is n2 so we cannot afford
time linear in this long side we can
only afford time
linear and square root and one into
so
to make this linear time
what we have to do is um
but the point is that most of the y's
are zeros
i mean if the number of edges in your
graph is only square root of two most of
your most of your vertices are going to
have no edges at all
and all you need to do is be able to
look up or what are the edges adjacent
to a vertex that has at least one edge
and for this you can use this
classic data structure of
friedman commemoration semi-ready
from 84 i think where they show how to
implement a sparse table efficiently you
can create this table in size order of
the size of a number of number of edges
and you can look up in constant time
so that's all we need to learn this one
yeah so this is what you'll achieve but
you won't actually do this
multiplication because otherwise it'll
be too long
okay um so the analysis is just four
steps at least at this level of
description it's easy phase one
okay oh we keep we keep a potential
function there's a potential function
that's going to go high
almost monotonically not quite
monotonically almost what's the
potential function
the potential function is just the
um the inner product of the current
u vector
which is the
the sine vector the current sine vector
with uh
the
um the true partition
so actually let u be the true partition
on the left
u dot x i
this will be one potential function
and the other one is for the other side
we have to keep both
growing to to show that each one is
growing um
v
dot y i
right so the vectors we have in the
algorithm are x i and y i u and v are
the true plus minus one vectors denoting
the partition and this is the inner
product so we'd like this to be very
high in magnitude both of these
when it's when it's uh n then you're
yeah okay so
in phase one of of the algorithm
in uh
log n iterations log n one iterations
um
u i
will reach
log n one
with high probability each of these
things with high probability
quickly what you
perhaps what you're going to do is it
that a u is mi plus 1 is independent of
you use a fixed vector as far as mi plus
1 is concerned we haven't used mi plus 1
yet
let's say whatever u is right you is
just telling you what the planting is up
to the state well or in the v yeah right
whatever you mean the x i and y exciting
stage i plus one is independent
so the random part of i plus one makes a
small dot product
much smaller than the top singular value
because it's a fixed vector as far as
it's concerned right that's how you're
going to beat this uh yes basically i
mean each at each step you at each step
you should win
the only only thing we need to make sure
is that you win over sufficiently many
steps so that
you actually recover planted partition
so the algorithm you you run this up to
log in
and you stop now if you were to keep
going with the same set of matrices
you're going to go to the top
eigenvector and i don't know if that's
any good
if you keep sampling and doing you'll be
fine you'll stay you'll stay high but
so um you see if you just do the top
eigenvector then you have no idea what
that's going to
do um
okay so in the first log in iterations
this u1 will get up a little bit
and
phase two
when it's between then it starts
doubling ui doubles
the language ui
till it reaches
square root n1
just to fix normalization see so use a
plus minus one factor yes
one
zero is a unit vector plus minus nice
divided by one over two you start out
about constant exactly okay you start
out constant you have to get up to root
n one
okay right exactly start constant um
right
so double still it reaches root n one
and then in phase three once you have
high inner product
uh every step
uh the zi
plus one
agrees with
either u or minus u
on three fourth of the coordinates
and so of course then
this implies that majority works
now the
this phase two is roughly what ravi was
describing
if you just write out the iteration
because of the independence
you you
if you already have
some correlation with the
with the planted assignment that's the
part that carries you
instead of doubling you can make this as
high as you want by making the edge
probability a little higher
now the first phase is the slightly
tricky one
because in the first phase
what we really have within this are two
little claims
one claim is that at each iteration
independent of what else is happening
with probability at least half
u
i
is at least half
so it doesn't go below at least one
fourth in our paper but
it stays at least a constant at every
iteration no matter what it was before
that's just because of some variance
that it has
each step there's enough variance
because of the independence that when
you run it you get at least constant
correlation
okay
but then
you also have
that with probability at least half
ui doubles
okay but it's only probably half so what
we need
is a sequence of a streak
of uh
log log n1 iterations
where you get the first one is at least
a constant and the rest double
but out of log n you will always have
log log n of any kind of streak that you
want and so that's the that's the streak
you need to get up to log n one
correlation then after that it's all
high probability every iteration doubles
um
okay
we just use uh so the proof requires
that we maintain the
the
um
we have to take this hypothesis and
expand it into eight different
conditions and induction but they're all
elementary the norms of
x and y and the norms of mx and my we
have to maintain the
infinity norm the two norm and the
fourth norm
and those help each other
so
um that's
as much detail as i thought i would go
into
um
i think it's a
very puzzling open problem as to what
the real complexity of
planted uh satisfiability is and whether
this algorithmic gap is
uh some explanation we can provide that
maybe matches a physical phenomenon like
like people have done
or at least suggested for for
satisfiability when there's no flight
well it seems to correspond to some
uh fragmentation of the solution space
here
less clear
why there is this gap much bigger gap
between n and n to the r over two
um in our paper we have concrete
distributions that we conjecture are
hard
uh explicit ones even satisfiable ones
so those are also i think potentially
good candidates for uh
trying to prove
hierarchies work or whatever you have
any other algorithm works
i'll stop